[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
it is time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as i mom explain it
all
clark kennedy students head back to
school next week and for some it'll be
their first time back
in a year and by now we're well aware of
the drawbacks and limitations of remote
learning but in a new poll by one poll
72 percent of parents say the concept of
virtual learning
is a game changer that will be around
for a long time after the pandemic
and they say their kids actually got a
lot of good habits out of learning
online
53 percent said their kids were focusing
better
46 percent said kids are asking more
questions
43 percent said their kids have become
better at multitasking and 41 percent
say
they have become more independent other
good habits that parents saw include
making better use of their time
pacing themselves teaching them their
new tech skills
and helping other kids with schoolwork
and studying up next let's talk back to
school shopping the national retail
federation reports the average family is
planning to spend
848.90 on back to school supplies this
year
but i have some tips that can help you
cut that amount way down
real simple.com says you should reuse
and recycle
you probably have a lot of things that
were from last year that you can use
again
give those backpacks and lunch boxes a
good wash and start going through
supplies that you have at home to see if
you have extra pencils pens binders and
notebooks
that you can put back into rotation put
off some clothes shopping right now
your kid's not going to need that
sweatshirt anytime soon so let them wear
their summer clothes for now
and buy the wintry clothing items a
little later and bonus the back to
school clothes will be on sale by then
to make room for the holiday stuff
and buy plane and diy get plain white
binders and simple folders
and let your kids get creative with
stickers and markers to personalize them
and finally something your kids are
talking about a tick talker named bear
bailey has gone viral with videos of
himself
singing in a gas station market an
employee he calls mama
will give him free stuff if he agrees to
sing
sometimes it's acapella sometimes it's
the song playing in the store
him who's the master when you feel it in
your body you found somebody who
makes you change your ways like hanging
with your boo
said you act like you're ready but you
don't really know
wow talk about talent i think usher
would be proud of that one and now
you've had a momsplaining we'll be right